kenya's supreme court has rejected
challenges to the presidential election
result upholding william ruto's victory
ruto was declared rather the winner by a
narrow margin in mid-august but
opposition candidate raila odinga
had pointed to irregularities and
presented a petition to the court some
members of the electoral commission that
validated the vote had themselves
disowned the result calling the vote
counting process opaque
with more let's cross over to tw
correspondent felix moringa who's
standing by for us at the supreme court
there in nairobi felix was this the
expected outcome or is it come up as a
bit of a shock
well in the morning we didn't know what
will happen but immediately the judges
started reading their judgment or and
addressing the various issues that had
been presented as petitions
then one could clearly see the direction
that this particular petition was going
to because
some of the key things like did the
presidential candidate manage to get the
50 percent plus one
vote
which is a constitutional threshold the
judges said the candidate garnered that
there was also a question about the form
34a which is the form that is used to
relay election results from the polling
centers to the national telling center
again the petitioners had argued that
there were discrepancies but the court
found otherwise so immediately some of
those things started appearing and the
judges started
saying what the finding of the court was
and even a scrutiny report that had been
done by the registrar of the judiciary
also pointed to a particular direction
so as the judges started reading one
could clearly tell where this particular
decision was headed to
are the opposition camp and their
supporters likely to accept today's
outcome
so yesterday in different
church services the president's elect
now president william ruto and raila
odinga was the main opposition candidate
in different events they said that
whatever decision would be given by the
court they would agree to that but
immediately the court gave its decision
the azimio deputy presidential candidate
mother karua just posted on her twitter
and she said that she respects the court
decision but she does not agree with the
ruling
okay what about people's reaction there
so far if there's been any yet can we
expect to see more stability in the
country
certainly
most of the people had fatigue of of
this electoral process because as you
remember this electoral process began
immediately after the 2017 general
election so people are already tired
they wanted to move on you could hear
people say we want this petition to
either be thrown out or the presidency
validated because we are tired with this
electoral cycle but immediately the
decision was announced by the chief
justice in kenya
people in different parts of the country
broke into song and dance and
we shall be keeping a keen eye on
what else will be taking place where
where people are celebrating and we
shall at least try the very least to
bring you thoughts uh as soon as we get
there all right felix thank you very
much for that thorough roundup of
today's events felix moringa for us in
nairobi
you